o la ficción y campaña política estos
fueron los activos usados por la
vicepresidenta de argentina cristina
fernández sobre el pedido de la fiscalía
de 12 años de prisión y su
inhabilitación política vitalicia por
supuestas irregularidades en la
adjudicación de obras públicas durante
su mandato
absolutamente nada de lo que dijeron fue
probado pero no es que no fue probado y
entonces bueno hay duda no no no
solamente no fue probado sino que además
se comprobó que era exactamente al revés
de lo que decían fernández también
aseguró que la sentencia ya estaba
escrita haciendo referencia al alegato
final del fiscal diego él salió de un
juicio que comenzó en 2019 en este se le
investigaba por presunta corrupción en
la concesión de 51 obras públicas a un
empresario afín a fernández en la región
de santa cruz en el sur del territorio
argentino
la vicepresidenta argumentó que no
existen pruebas en su contra y aprovechó
para lanzar una pugna al ex presidente
mauricio macri
floro lo que era un sistema judicial
totalmente compenetrado con los
servicios de inteligencia y obviamente
dirigido direccionado creado este
sistema desde la propia casa rosada- a
través de mauricio macri
la declaración del fiscal encendió los
ánimos en argentina el lunes posiciones
opuestas se encontraron en las calles de
buenos aires
tocar vamos a salir a la calle por qué
yo soy parte de la generación a la que
le salvó la vida
histórico porque por fin empezamos a ver
el fin de la corrupción la sentencia
tiene todavía mucho camino por recorrer
fernández tiene inmunidad política hasta
2023 por ser presidenta del senado y
vicepresidenta además podrá apelar la
decisión se espera que el veredicto
llegue a finales de este año y para que
éste sea ejecutado debe ser ratificado
por la corte suprema de justicia